you know I I okay I shouldn't even be
saying this on on wax as they say but
yeah I was thinking about doing not the
old stand-up character that I was doing
but I've been thinking about doing a new
stand of character yeah like what else
Allah meets let me see what it's like
well see I'll try it
ok I'll pitch it because you know why is
it at me you know what I'm gonna pitch
it why because a I'll probably never do
it and B because I feel like it's it's
not a bad thing now to pull the curtain
back a little bit because we're in the
Internet age pull that [ __ ] back there
nothing is special the whole family's in
the bathtub when you pull that curtain
back you see the whole family's yeah
yeah that's really you know don't you
hope for when you pull that curtain back
you hope to see all of them in a line
just like like the stickers on the back
of a minivan it's like all lined up and
a dog and a cat coat to just do a joke
just a family doing coke behind that
bathroom curtain that's what comedy is
really dude think about it
order me a bag of yams brother you need
some sweet potatoes and a [ __ ] in the
slingshot it's Christmas
some kind of [ __ ] self-made well you
got to talk about Christmas juice to do
the character well case nobody Jesus
Christ dude all right I feel like we
invited here to do character you just
been talking about all or some Runkle
I've got my for my is Christ forearms
are sweating somebody's gonna bake you
over the holidays yeah your [ __ ] arms
are wet my arm stroke I don't know took
some dick pills of the am/pm mod I
figured I was gonna get in here might as
well get some uppers in me I [ __ ] I
slept here last night I was in the
[ __ ] I'll add some nigiri and then
this morning and had a [ __ ] turkey
sandwich clean myself up took a couple
of [ __ ] rhinos yeah you're ready for
the outback anyway here's my character
[ __ ] me
anyway this is literally what I was
thinking yeah well like what if I did
stand-up uh-huh
see this is gonna be the dumbest [ __ ]
thing ever well but still just get it
out I [ __ ] pitch this to a couple of
buddies of mine the other night I was
like hey man you know what might be
funny cuz they know like the old
stand-up care applause no I got a
I'm rolling so it doesn't I gotta make
sure it doesn't work I gotta [ __ ]
just [ __ ] stomp it into the ground
first and I pitched it to them and they
went I don't know so that's why I just
want to preface it by saying other
people who I respect in comedy one's a
writer one's a director not stand-up
never heard of them do it and they went
I don't know [ __ ] character here's
the character dude a Chatty Bad Santa
sweaty arms whatever what if you never
do the character it just keeps being
there what if I just go on stage and
pitch a character and never do it yeah
this [ __ ] podcast just goes in
perpetuity through so character dude
well there's really no are you there's
me guys Milwaukee yeah should he fight
that guy yeah hey hey here's my here's
here's my Brendan Schaub personation
ready it's just a couple words okay hey
Dana White that's a it's a three word
impersonation oh no I don't know B
listen Dana White yeah how many
countries are there look it up chin hey
chill my name looking up coffee we'll
see you in our Toledo so here's my
character Santa Anna gonna release some
special tickets where are you gonna be a
dry bro
or how about instead of hey Dana wait
this is my new listen Dana White so
that's my Brian
[Laughter]
[Music]
so hey Dana White so there that's 250
episodes of TFA TK in 2 minutes you want
to see that there you go
let's do it 200 - 200 all 252 episodes
of TFA TK in 2 minutes we just do it ok
just added head up then we'll package
that up so and then they get that little
redheaded guy in there that guy who says
who knows what probably a disease you're
talking about rito-san - yeah cheeto
Santino some guy named a for a [ __ ]
chip you know I didn't watch so god
named after somebody gets dropped off in
a van every afternoon and thrown it into
a machine where people put change in and
get you out of a [ __ ] chip bro get
your life together dude it's your life
with your [ __ ] cousin funny boy
[ __ ] beautiful thing you crazy [ __ ]
you [ __ ] Joey Diaz that's Joey yes
when Michael Rapaport Instagram oh yeah
my personal good you listener don't rope
thing you're gonna drop that dog and get
hit by a car and then that happens I
want to talk to some I'm a white
privileged white GOG Jewish Alice can
assi rare silverback Hebrew and I [ __ ]
porzingis Oh Carmelo Anthony you [ __ ]
Donald Trump da da look at his [ __ ]
guys gonna jump through this table and
hurt himself you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh we [ __ ] fell I [ __ ] told you uh
here's my character okay no I don't want
the character do another one and I'll
guess who it is you know I'll do one and
you get alright I'll do this one uh let
me think of one
these people we only know how for the
same people
[Laughter]
this practice in that's okay he'll do
what I mean I'm quite happy to go you
[ __ ] down the street now you're gonna
get splashed with water when the [ __ ]
bus drives by you dumb [ __ ] you got
splashed with water you [ __ ] big
stink Donald
listen come on the [ __ ] Paris climate
Accord you [ __ ] idiot you listen a
guy McCrone you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
you [ __ ] unemployment you know why -
why does it mean dick stink Donald you
can look just like each other that's a
perfectly the same you're my [ __ ] dad
and I'm [ __ ] angry their kids went to
the same school yeah you had your
[ __ ] hair straighten cuz you don't
want to look like me you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you yeah Ravin force it
sounds like somebody stuffed that movie
casino who into a ginger it's like
what's going on here and also while
we're gonna do Spike Lee [ __ ] sucks
dick I'll say that that dudes had one
good movie and a bunch of bad outfits if
he weren't at the front of the Knicks
games nobody would give a [ __ ] about
that dude yeah you [ __ ] put my
[ __ ] money to sleep I'll put your
[ __ ] brain to sleep and just when
you're [ __ ] waking up in a [ __ ]
Hospital I'll be there to do it again
because I'm stupid you [ __ ] you me
why are you talking like that he's a
straight guy because I'll tell you why
it's casino it's a casino you went over
my [ __ ] ankle I stuck to you
we should reshoot casino yeah with
Michael Rapaport and I don't know like
Brian could play ace could play like ace
Rothschild the [ __ ] and Brendan
Brendan or Chris could play the Sharon
Stone part it's just rich people yelling
at each other man yeah it's all linear
that movie is [ __ ] that's some good
rich people yelling at each other though
one of the finest rich people yelling at
each other movies yeah oh yeah all right
do one more dude I'll do one there they
go let me do your character all right
okay do my girl and I was in a train
wreck [ __ ] I'm trying not to laugh is it
so hot in here that one that's pretty
good one that's Patrick I'm gonna pitch
this to you because I [ __ ] god dude I
want to go home [ __ ] this [ __ ] thing
Christmas [ __ ] man this whole thing was
Christmassy you got that on I got a
[ __ ] hat that's raising my
temperature what I'm sticking with it
I'm [ __ ] sweating through fur I'm
[ __ ] sweating you yeah where were you
when I was playing in the NBA six on six
celebrity basketball you piece of [ __ ]
yeah
you couldn't beat Omarosa in a
one-on-one Dick's thing Donald extinct
Donald you're out here causing all this
traffic I'm [ __ ] rich and I'm yelling
at you nobody showed up to your [ __ ]
inauguration you can't suck to you okay
so here's the care who cares why doesn't
Michael care so much about it oh well
you got to be passionate he's passionate
about his passion it's a good point but
it's like why take it out like take it
out on somebody else take it out on the
coach of the [ __ ] Knicks that guy's
been a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] for 20
years
well that team is garbage wait a minute
you're talking about taking out his
political views that he would have aimed
at Trump on the
bigger boxers be a little more I don't
know it be interesting yeah just try
something different dude that's
definitely different he's politically
ranting people do this they gather
Internet and they [ __ ] I will say
that there's that I love that we live in
an age that the Internet is still the
Wild West that you can literally get on
the internet and say and call the
[ __ ] president whatever the [ __ ] you
want and you can do anything about it
people threatened to kill him didn't
Madonna say that I'd like that yeah let
me move it where you at Madonna yeah I
can kill him if you want kill somebody
kill somebody kill the Konex
your senior citizen that's [ __ ]
trying to you know [ __ ] you know yes
speaking of the Knicks is she [ __ ]
half of them do dynamic what if Chris
started dating Madonna that would be a
Power Move I wish she would dude I wish
you would here's a thing he's got a
chance to really hook up with some old
senior citizen hotties before they you
know go to heaven or don't go to heaven
and there's a few out there oh yeah
Jessica Lange so yeah dude Artie Lange
party Lange you know ant yeah I did I
thank you let's see the character okay
so here's the character okay it's
essentially it's me it's me doing
stand-up okay some jokes you know write
some jokes try to get up there for a few
minutes oh yeah definitely didn't maybe
I might even pilfer some of the jokes
from the other character yeah maybe
that's a specific bit probably not
here's what it is though it's me with
maybe a slightly different name and a
very very short well-made wig I could
see it and it's not one of those things
where it's like oh why why can't why
wouldn't you just we'll just take this
stupid wig off and do the jokes well no
this character has his own specific
point of view on things about I don't
know mostly what it is though is me
doing stand-up yep slightly different
name mm-hmm and a little short short
brown wig
I could see that I could see you in the
smallest wig ever like blendra tiny wig
just on the back of my head and I would
have a name like Pete or maybe Philip
Stanley Stanley Daniel just something
different yeah
bunion bunions a good name my cute name
Palma Paul I feel like you would have
any name that would be cute for a rabbit
would be cute for you and if I and if I
muffin cotton thumper Jenkins ladies and
gentlemen one hand I keep smacking
against the other means wonderful a
sound for thumper Jacob hey guys what's
up I'm thumper Jake yeah and here's
thumper Jenkins and he's got three tasty
yams he's about to fire across what it's
like just and I did I have like a super
colorful name but I don't but I just uh
yeah
speak very Canadian like spunk Wilson
spunk yeah Spock Wilson spunk
taste test Wilson branch and sniff
Wilson they yelled him so I think this
would be something that could be
interesting so technically it wouldn't
be me I wouldn't be doing our union and
doing it for us or not oh that's it no
that's I haven't worked out the rest of
it
that's crazy brother you told us all
that yeah yeah train this is the worst
inning this like boys on the side or
whatever
Wow you know what's crazy as my sister
can't even read but what does it have to
do with us right now hope you enjoyed
that video and you can watch another and
you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices some guy just brings you one
option not this guy
two options watch one this one